like most learning to drive jade
nicholas craves more independence
she wants to be able to give lifts to
her younger siblings and go wherever
whenever but under new proposals being
put forward to parliament
that may not be allowed if i don't learn
to drive at night then i'm never gonna
get practice doing it so once i can do
it
it will seem unnatural whereas if you
learn to do it slowly it'll become more
natural
and the whole point of learning to drive
is so that i can take my sister's places
come september mps will consider calls
for a graduated license
it would see new drivers under 25 banned
from giving lifts to friends
and only able to accept experienced
motorists as passengers instead
they may not be allowed to drive at
night either and could potentially face
speed restrictions too
in an effort to improve road safety it
would make a huge difference so it's
been estimated
and that if we were to introduce
graduated driver licensing
in the in britain there'd be 400 um
less death and serious injuries per year
drivers under the age of 25 make up
seven percent of license holders
however they are involved in 20 of all
fatal
and serious road accidents 45 percent of
those accidents occurred due to drivers
inexperience
or failure to look properly the story of
fern campbell reveals the devastating
impact behind those statistics
she was 19 when she was killed in a
crash four years ago
as the passenger in a car driven by a
friend who'd only passed their test
six weeks earlier very very proud dad
and um
always will be always will be very
difficult to talk
about her if she's uh
still compilation not here you know
but some driving instructors believe a
blanket ban won't work and suggest
so-called black box data recorders
should be used instead
to determine a new driver's risk black
boxes work on
acceleration braking cornering and speed
so if you've got someone who's driving
too
fast or you've got someone who's taking
corners and and flagging off the
the black box technology that way then
you can act and you can step
in and you can have some kind of system
in place that supports that
it seems all can agree our roads could
and should be safer
but there's far from a consensus on the
best way to achieve that
iva bennett sky news